- We've talked about
former President Trump's
ridiculous lawsuit against
a bunch of big tech firms
that de-platformed him,
and one of the arguments that he's making
is that these big tech firms
were deputized by the federal government
to effectively work as an arm
of the federal government.
Now, that is something that can happen
if the federal government
contracts with a private company,
then sometimes that private company
can be an arm of the government,
but these are private companies
that haven't contracted
with the federal government
and they haven't been
deputized by the government.
And, by the way, the government
that he's talking about,
given the timeframe, is the government
that he was running at the time,
which is particularly ridiculous.
But, as many people have pointed out,
this isn't so much a lawsuit
that has any chance of winning
so much as a fundraising effort
by Trump and his campaign.
So, look, the metrics for
success are very different.
So we're going to see Trump
in court for a little while,
but not for very much longer.